what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
have been pondering this for like the
last couple days or so I've been
thinking about the aftermath to infinity
war which by the way this will have
spoilers you know for some of the stuff
in infinity war but I was thinking about
the aftermath to infinity war and the
number one question at least with
regards to the whole black panther thing
that I've been thinking about is are
they gonna make a new black panther and
if they do
who's the new black panther gonna be
because T'Challa is dead
he's gone like he died at the end of
infinity war and so it's like okay if
he's if he's one of the many superheroes
who died someone has to be king or queen
of Wakanda somebody has to run the
country and in his stead who will take
his place now my first thought went to
Shuri right like you know I mean there's
there's the Sharia there's a Quay but
like my first thought went to Shuri
because that's how it happened in the
comics those are guys who don't know
Shuri did become Black Panther at one
point in time and actually she was black
panther right up until the incursions
that collapse of the multiverse to start
a Secret Wars going into all-new
all-different marvel so this all played
out in Black Panther vol 5 and in fact
really like sharees desire to become
black panther really kind of predates
why Panther vol 5 it goes way back I
mean ever since she was introduced but
the whole basis behind this was that
sure he always wanted to be black
panther she always wanted to have the
mantle the problem with this was that
her brother was the rightful heir he was
he was the one that earned the title of
black panther and even when people like
Eric Hill monger had defeated him and
then took his place as the new black
panther he ultimately came back and won
the mantle back and so shuri's desire to
become a new black panther initially
happened in I want to say it was vol 5 i
Reginald Hudlin
and she ultimately didn't get it because
she you know what had happened in this
story it gets kind of weird cuz it's
kind of easy to merge with doom war what
had happened in that story and in really
the first six issues of vol 5 is that
there was an attempt by Namor the
Submariner who was part of a group
called the Cabal and the Cabal was
basically a group of forces led by
Doctor Doom that would essentially
attempt to like invade Wakanda or at
least you know exercise the goals of
Doctor Doom the result was that black
panther turned it down and then he was
attacked and essentially like knocked
out like left in a comatose state
basically he was absent from the throne
and so because he was absent what had
happened is sure he had tried to take
the to take the throne a black panther
and she went
all the trials and succeeded in all of
them because she's an exceedingly
skilled combatant she's really really
good at fighting and so she had gone
through like all the trials and then
once she took the heart-shaped herb that
allowed her to approach the Panther God
or the Panther goddess and when the
Panther goddess looked on looked on
sharee she declined she said you know
the Panther goddess basically said you
cannot be the new Black Panther because
your heart's not here you're not doing
this because what Conda legitimately
needs a leader you're doing this because
you've always wanted be Black Panther
and so ultimately she was turned down
eventually just hala came back to
Tolliver wheel and went back to being
alive Panther and then what had happened
is there was an event called do more and
do more or no maybe it was not on so I
guess that's not correct um there was
but maybe it was doom knows before doom
or something happened and I can't ruffed
on my head something happened Sheree had
undertale like she basically donned the
black of the Black Panther mantle in the
first place and then she ended up you
know going through the whole process
like after she had undertaken the mantle
he's basically used like the costume of
the Black Panther fought off the forces
and then ultimately she went forward and
an approach like the Panther God again
and was awarded the role of Black
Panther and so that goes in to do more
and do more was a story where Doctor
Doom invaded well actually he
orchestrated a coup d'etat in Wakanda
basically like funding all these rebel
insurgents I want to say was a destory
funding the rebel insurgents that
allowed them to rise to prominence and
then asked who was there now between the
start of doom war and the time that sure
he became like panther there was
Jonathan Hickman's fantastic for at
least the first segment of it and in
Jonathan Hickman in the beginning of the
Fantastic Four so I'm sorry towards the
end of the Fantastic Four story black
panther had approached to Reed Richards
and said I need your I need your help
for something and Reed was like okay
we've been friends for a very long time
I'll help you with you know the best way
I know how and so Reed Richards needed
to be a witness and the reason why was
because what de chollet did is he went
to the to the necropolis the city of the
Dead and approached the Panther God and
said you know I know I cannot become the
new black panther I want to become
something else instead and so what ended
up happening is the Panther God tested
the metal of of Black Panther and
essentially saying like you Reed
Richards who stand before me right now
do you attest to this man's worth and
Reid said yes
I would trust this man with my life and
so the Panther God turned like Panther
in returned to chala into the king of
the Dead and so what that meant is he
had all the same powers he had before
but sure he also had all the Black
Panther powers she led Wakanda and then
Black Panther was more of like an
advisor and then that goes in to do more
and what doom war does is it brings in
this idea that the dr. doom had
basically invaded Wakanda he's set in
motion this coup d'etat while the whole
civil war was taking place black panther
and ensure he had taken off to go
recruit like the x-men the Fantastic
Four some of the Avengers do more things
like that
basically the whole superhero community
based out of North America while all
that happened dr. diem infiltrated
Wakanda managed to get the vibranium for
himself and then absorb like used it to
amplify as magical energy and so what
happened is Black Panther ended up
gathering all the earth superheroes they
traveled to Latveria where Doctor Doom
was located and then dr. doom because he
had godlike power with all the magical
amplification that came from the
vibranium black panther rendered all
vibranium across the world inert he
basically destroyed it all no one says
that's not doom or happen before he
became king of the Dead that's what it
was because there was a meeting between
Reed Richards and Black Panther when
they were talking like when Reed
Richards asked what are you gonna do now
that you don't have vibranium and black
panther says well we used our wealth to
buy up like a bunch of debt from
countries so we've got trillions and
trillions of dollars we're far from
being broke so that's right so it was it
was black panther who was coming toast
sure he became black panther shortly
after that and then there was doom war
and then there was him becoming king of
the dead so that's how that happened but
regardless that's how sure he became
Black Panther and she stayed that way up
until the time when like Thanos and the
Cabal invaded earth and then she died
when they basically invaded Wakanda and
like destroy the city like well a minute
Acropolis is already destroyed because
of a vendor's vs. x-men but it was when
like it was when everything was popping
off so basically she died and and that
was the end of her going into all-new
all-different marvel black panther got
the mantle back and then sure he was
kind of you know free floating around
but nonetheless that's how sure he
became black panther a long-winded
explanation for an otherwise relatively
simple thing uh but nonetheless you know
my initial thought went to Shuri because
I was like okay she's been black panther
around the comics the problem is that in
in the comics she was exceedingly good
at fighting in the movies she's just a
really really good she's really good at
technology but she hasn't shown any any
indication that she's been a very good
wit T'Challa he was raised since birth
to become a good fighter so he's got
decades of experience in in you know
hand-to-hand combat and weapons use and
all that kind of good stuff
and how to use the various technologies
of Wakanda at his disposal for offensive
and defensive purposes at the same time
sure he doesn't have any of that in
terms of combat training she's just
really good at tech at the same time
what you also have is you have a Quay
and she she's the general of the of the
normal Asha and and she is fierce she's
actually one of my favorite characters
from the movies oh I love her character
oh man like she's she's she's awesome
like to see her do her whole thing she's
amazing I would say that that she's seen
she seems to stand as the most viable
alternative for a new black panther but
historically speaking aside from a
couple instances here and there for the
most part the black panther role seems
to really be more of a monarch role and
the sense of this passed down from
generation to generation now that does
not mean that someone outside of the
T'Challa family line can become Black
Panther as long as they can defeat the
existing black panther and as long as
they can you know consume the heart
shape herb and not die then like they
can become Black Panthers such was the
case with Eric hill monger the other
reason why I say it seems to be more of
a monarch line is because more often
than not when you look at the people who
have been Black Panther throughout
Marvel Comics they have been by by blood
in some way associated with T'Challa
himself for example two challahs uncle
was the rainy black panther until tatata
was old enough to overt you know to
undertake the role and then he became
black panther so really two challahs
father was more of like a steward for
what connor than anything else but the
fact remains like that that really seems
to be the direction they go within the
comics but the MCU has changed a lot of
things they've shifted up a lot of
situations especially with the nature of
Sheree Sheree especially has been
changed I like the idea that she's a
tech geek I like the idea that she's a
walking meme factory because she's
amazing like I love the character of
Sheree but when I think about the whole
black panther idea there's a couple of
ways that they can go so they could just
give it to acclaim to say okay cool
you're the new Black Panther which would
be awesome you know and she's hardcore
and she plays the role that two challahs
uncle did where she's a steward for the
throne until tajalli comes back because
of the way your characters been been
portrayed so far I have a hard time
believing that she would refuse to give
up the role of Black Panther when
T'Challa came back she probably just
hand it over and say no you're the
rightful king
you know I will I will hand it over to
you but we also have seen a little bit
of Merc
the Black Panther movie she basically
made the argument my job is to serve the
existing throne like that that's what I
serve I serve the throne I serve whoever
happens to be king I don't serve to
chala
and so the others there's the idea that
like she's loyal to the throne and the
idea is like you know with her simply
saying like I am the new Black Panther
now I'm gonna stay this way like I'm not
I'm not leaving you know and you can't
make me no no no no you know that'd be
kind of be kind of funny you know with
you know seeing that seeing that whole
thing play out I think it'd be cool I
think it'd be pretty interesting um you
could see what's his name from the
gorilla clan make a make a play you know
Missy Anne Bach who make a play for the
throne that's entirely possible I don't
think you would because of the the the
kind of bond that was shared between the
two of them and infinity war
there's obviously they've obviously
T'Challa and mbaku have obviously gone
from being like enemies to having a lot
of respect and admiration for each other
and so you know even even then like it
seems they're more hints or like blood
you know brothers in the sense that
they're like hey look we've fought
side-by-side and you know mbaku was like
I will fight you to the end that kind of
a situation so I see I don't really see
him refusing to give it up which means
they might go with Sheree and if they do
there's a couple ways to make that work
just because Sheree is not a great
hand-to-hand combatant in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe does not mean that
one
she can't be taught to be you know
taught to be a great fighter and two she
can't find ways to work around it that's
the cool thing is you know we generally
associate the black panther mythos with
a warrior you know a tried and true
physical combat warrior who's good at
fighting who's good at weapons use and
who is really really smart but it could
just be that because she's not a great
fighter she uses technology at her side
you know she's not the best fighter ever
but she's got all this technology at her
disposal like Iron Man Tony Stark's not
a good hand-to-hand combat and you meet
Tony Stark and you probably beat the
crap out of him he's just not that great
of a fighter but because of all the
technology it has it hasn't you know he
has at his disposal he's a really
effective superhero you know I don't
really see them going in the direction
of Shuri getting her own black pants or
her own Iron Man armor although that
would be awesome that would be cool what
would that look like you know just just
to kind of just kind of hit that for a
second what would that look like if
there was like a black panther Iron Man
armor how awesome would that be I mean
okay
one it would probably be made of
vibranium - I imagine sure he would make
it because I'd be the cool thing sure he
gets her hand on stark tech
be awesome like she cuz I mean the whole
world breaker armor is in Wakanda we
know that because of how infinity were
ended so I'm not world breaker the
Hulkbuster is in Wakanda we know that
because of how infinity war ended
so if Cherie were to be able to like
reverse engineer stark Tech and then
make like a black panther iron man armor
that would be insane okay that's how you
make it work that's how you pull those
okay that's how you make that when I saw
you pulled together so you have Sheree
who's basically like what Honda's Tony
Stark but like she seems a whole lot
smarter than he is which i think is a
really or at least much better with
technology you know like she there our
technology is way beyond what Tony Stark
has and so I like that idea so you have
Sheree who reverse engineers the
Hulkbuster suit because Ironman still on
Titan as far as we're aware so we still
out there by Saturn so she reverse
engineers the Hulkbuster armor and then
uses that to create a black panther suit
and then she's crowned the new black
panther because she's the sister of the
existing black panther who's dead a soul
just falls down the monarchy line so she
has a black panther Ironman suit she
dons it teams up with with Ironman I
have no idea but dude that would be
amazing okay how could I mean don't tell
me that wouldn't be cool you cannot tell
me with a straight face that it wouldn't
be awesome to see Sheree flying around
and like a black panther Ironman suit
and I'll be honest I'm probably gonna be
like I'm gonna get some hate for this
and I don't really care I feel like
sharees Ironman suit would be better
than Tony Stark's eye I feel like it
would with oh okay wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute okay what if what
if the Indo sim suit comes from Sheree
and that's the black panther okay those
you guys I don't know the endo sim suit
I say I mean it was like up until the
bleeding edge armor which i think is the
one that he uses and all-new
all-different marvel up until that point
i would say that like the endo sim is
the coolest suit of armor than ironman
ever had it was based on the symbionts
like venom carnage that kind of thing it
was based on those symbionts and the
idea was the the the suit would respond
to his commands and and traveled to him
no matter where he was and he could like
he could create all currently he had
like an invisible visor on his face so
you could see his face but you couldn't
actually penetrate the suit um I don't
think I could shape-shift in the in the
suit but he could do all kinds of crazy
stuff and then it was like all the
standard powers that he has
it was a really versatile suit of armor
it was based on a combination of the
extremists tech and the mmm venom you
know the Venom symbiote and so because
of that I could see her creating more of
like a fluid suit not really based on
the symbiote tech because as far as
we're aware of venom doesn't exist in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
symbiote stone exists we've never seen
it but I could see her creating like an
Iron Man suit that's more of like a
fluid suit it's more like a liquid metal
suit and then of course it just like
responds to her whims and wants and
different things like that
maybe the suit operates like like she's
like you know like fighter the suit just
kind of moves on her behalf you know in
the sense of like you know it can go
forward and fight for her or you know it
it can allow her to move in ways you
know give her information or there's any
number of ways that they could do it but
like that would be awesome if we got
like a liquid metal Iron Man suit
basically the endo sim suit from from
from Shuri that would be pretty sweet
like I would definitely dig that ya know
I mean it's it seems like an awesome
idea you know her becoming the new black
panther having her own you know Iron Man
esque black panther suit that would be
pretty boss like that'd be pretty
awesome to see an Avengers for I don't
know if we will I mean I figure like if
we were ever going to see anything like
that it would be in Avengers 4 because
there's no like I mean as far as you
know looking at the movie looking at
what happened infinity war and looking
at the layout of the movie I honestly
don't see a lot of those superheroes
coming back until like the end you know
when it's like let the conflict end and
whoever it is probably Carol Danvers
takes the gauntlet and like fixes
everything either that or she gets the
gauntlet fixes everything and then they
fight Thanos which you know Thanos is a
lot weaker in the movies that he has in
the comics so I don't know how that
fight would go but still I mean I don't
really see like black panther returning
or any of those characters coming back
until near the end of the movie or at
the end of the movie I think that's
gonna be the MCS way of saying like
everybody whose contracts up you're not
gonna see them come back they're gonna
stay dead because for whatever reason
they didn't come back and then everybody
whose contracts are continuing on
they're gonna continue which means that
Bucky Barnes will probably become
Captain America at least for a little
while then they'll probably shift it
over to Sam Wilson which I think is a
good idea and then you know a few other
people here and there in terms of you
know moving moving things around but
still you know fun theories I love doing
these theory videos that's one of the
things people tend to forget I think
people get so swept up and whether or
not something would actually happen they
don't stop to think about the fact that
it's just fun to talk about whether it
would happen or not regardless of how
ridiculous it seems that's the fun part
it's talking about this stuff you know
coming up with these ideas and crazy
theories and so on itself
that's the point of all this is to just
have fun with it all but anyway guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you